amusé de la guerre économique contre la
russie est condamnable depuis le départ
comme on l'a vu ces dernières années les
sanctions sont une arme à double
tranchant
elles peuvent causer des dommages
comparable sinon plus important aux
auteurs et développeurs de ces sanctions
rebonjour gauthier nous avions relevé
une petite phrase tout à l'heure dans le
discours de vladimir poutine sur le
caractère factice de l'ukraine synonyme
solo vous de l'ultra comptèrent
conservatisme qui a pignon sur rue
finalement russie oui parce que la
russie revendique ou non de ce qu'on
appelle la rousse de kiev l'a finalement
la possession de l'ukraine mais là où il
ya quelque chose de finalement presque
comique ce que les les les acides et les
thuriféraires du crest nature faire de
poutine 10 à partir du 10e siècle
jusqu'au 19ème siècle n'a pas eu d'état
ukrainien
c'est faux mais admettons si vous voulez
bien on va faire une lapalissade avant
la création pour la russie de l'est de
la russie l'état de la russie qui a vite
il n'y avait pas la russie après la
création de l'état des rues si il y à la
russie tout ça pour vous dire que au
fond
chaque événement historique ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons ne
faisons pas aujourd'hui créer à terme la
tradition futur la tradition de la
russie c'est d'avoir été quasiment oui
vous fondez veut parler varègues au 9e
siècle
avant ce neuvième siècle il n'y avait
pas la russie je veux dire par là que
les événements fonde encore une fois les
traditions de demain et prétendre quand
bien même l'ukraine n'existerait que
depuis deux trois ans évidemment ce
qu'il faut mais quand bien même ça veut
dire qu'à un certain moment il ya des
gens qui ont dit oui nous voulons nous
avons cette volonté commune de vivre
dans un état à partir de là il n'y a pas
de raison que cette volonté soit décrié
ou daigné même si on rappelle que c'est
une nation très jeune oui mais bien sûr
mais il y a des nations très jeune qui
veut dans dans le dans le monde si vous
voulez la l'antériorité historique ne
justifie rien on pourra toujours trouver
des ukrainiens qui vous diront mais
avant 869 avant l'état russe nous étions
là vous trouverez un russe qui dira mais
non b pas du tout c'était moi
voyez c'est une querelle sans fin
l'antériorité historique ne signifie
rien à partir du moment où il ya des
volontés politiques qui disent nous
voulons vivre ensemble nous voulons
créer un état c'est tout et à partir de
là dans quelques siècles on dira mais la
tradition est là aussi elle est parmi
ceux qui ont des déclaré qu'il voulait
vivre ensemble ça n'a aucun sens cette
allusion à l'intériorité historique
revenant sur les déclarations dans le
domaine économique de vladimir poutine
il a dit vouloir soutenir ces
initiatives privées donc dans l'économie
c'est un serpent de mer en russie oui
c'est un serpent de mer c'est un serpent
de mer parce que à chaque fois et ça ça
n'est pas propre à vladimir poutine
s'est aussi propre à l'époque de boris
eltsine et boris eltsine avait laissé la
bride sur le cou aux investisseurs
étrangers v
que se passe-t-il quand vous voulez
favoriser l'investissement privé en
russie et l'investissement privé venant
d'entreprises russes ou d'acteurs
économiques russes vous avez toute cette
chaîne de corruption qui en quelque
sorte bloc met des bâtons dans les roues
à cette progression d'initiative frier
chaîne de corruption au plus bas étage
qui remonte et qui remontent parfois
jusqu aux potentats du régime russe et
d'une certaine manière qu est-ce qui
tient aussi le régime russe sinon cette
possibilité pour un certain nombre
d'échelons du des fonctionnaires de
l'état russe de s'en mettre plein les
poches et donc au final l'investissement
privé est limitée par ce type de
pratique est une pratique donc de
corruption et de détournement de
l'argent qui pourrait être un argent
productif donc on continue comme par le
passé les oui alors regardez quand même
ce pays qui dispose de toutes sortes de
richesse minerai autres évidemment le
génie russe aussi l'intelligence russe
qui est en quelque sorte bafouée et
méprisés par la présence de poutine il y
à tous en russie aux guerres carbure les
oui mais bien sûr et regardez où le fait
que vladimir poutine n'a jamais réussi
en 22 ans de pouvoir a diversifié
l'industrie russe est un point mais oui
initial pour qu'elle ne soit pas ultra
dépendante des cours des hydrocarbures
pour que cela puisse créer de nouvelles
classes sociales qui ne sont pas au bord
de l'abyme sur le plan économique rien
n'a été fait et lorsque poutine dit
vouloir se soucier du peuple c'est
encore une fois ses prix c'est une
indécence une indécence discursive une
indécence oratoire là est fou et donc à
partir de là vous voyez bien que la
rhétorique de vladimir poutine quand
vous disiez le monde parallèle oui c'est
qu'il est persuadé lui je suis pas
certain que ça soit un cynique
complaisent à jo dire il est persuadé
lui que c'est le sens de la marche de
l'histoire pour les russes mais en la
matière si vous voulez le fait de
n'avoir rien fait pour cette industrie
contribuer à maintenir dans la pauvreté
la précarité quantité de russes dont
nous avons dit tout à l'heure que
certains malgré tout sont des soutiens
idéologique à son régime si certains
s'en vont aussi il faut alors certains
s'en vont certains essayent de résister
et certains jeunes j'ai entendu dire
récemment c'était c'était une jeune
femme qui est je crois a été professeur
d'université qui disait je me doute bien
qu'il se passe des choses inadmissibles
en ukraine enfin je préfère faire comme
si je soutenais le président voyez ça
aussi c'est sont des éléments qui
contribuent à faire de la société russe
une société beau bloqués et sociétés de
type fascistoïde quand on sait j'en
terminerai là que par exemple les
enfants maintenant depuis trois quatre
ans à l'école sont embrigadés porte un
uniforme et en leur se chanter des
chants à la gloire de poutine s'est
aussi caractéristique de ce qu'est la
russie aujourd'hui malheureusement et
malgré le courage énorme de ceux qui
essaient de se battre contre cette
réalité ce constat merci pour votre
analyse gauthier rybinski merci